foreign
[Music]
let's play a thing together like ah dude
I don't know how big that lag is going
to be but let's go for it
yeah it's more of a soundscape at that
point soundscape yeah yeah so the reason
it just us because Jake's not as much of
a nerd as we are about anime I guess no
sorry blade I saw some whips from chains
sorry release before everybody leaves oh
whoa it's not it's not a nerdy anime
podcast actually well I mean it doesn't
mean we can't start it off like one yeah
because when I was doing something like
bar research and I came across some
really cool uh animatics for
um chainsaw man uh that were posted on
Twitter which is just super super cool
because uh
they would there's all these shots
basically they'd previously with blender
and then they make the you know this
grayscale render of 3D camera motion
with some placeholder objects which
eventually is going to be kind of filled
in with animation
but they use that as the base plate to
animate the main character jumping
around and doing crazy stunts so I think
similar techniques are used with like
Attack on Titan yeah I remember that
shot of him ziplining through the whole
city and yeah so excuse me perspective
stuff starts in 3D they have like a
placeholder kind of thing and then
they're just like look just make the guy
jump around in the scene go for it you
know there's a few keyframes probably
but uh do they hand draw over the
renders or do they keep the renders and
then just add like an animated character
in well I didn't see like a 3D animated
character in the scene it was just like
a background played of the camera with
swooping across this big room with some
people in it and then the character was
just like roughly sketched on top of
this super low quality render
and I was just like I was kind of
inspired I was like man that'd be cool
to do something like that in our anime
video
yeah because we're making an anime video
yeah which I guess some people might
know but not a lot we keep talking about
it yeah so this is one of those things
where like we have this really cool
video we're working on but we haven't
shown anything because you kind of want
to be the first ones to to do it
and then once we do it we're like we're
gonna show people how we did it
and people can do the technique
themselves but
you know like I think the thing that's
inspiring about the chainsaw man thing
is this idea of just being able to put
together a vision and like have it kind
of come together into an actual
aesthetically pleasing frame you know
without having to spend as much time as
you used to have to uh do on it you can
also plan it better so
you know we
last year like Dean started
experimenting with the the Spider-Man
shot and actually started with Arcane
didn't it it start with an Arcane like
stable diffusion model yeah it was
literally I just I think I you had
showed me some crazy stuff with stable
diffusion I
started testing it out on video because
I'd seen people were doing like uh sort
of like prompt videos where they would
it would run off of a prompt and just
denoise over a bunch of frames so it
kind of like warp into this weird
psychedelic thing but uh there was this
image damage thing and you know I didn't
see anybody using it so I like came in
the studio one morning just filmed me
doing like crazy movements and then ran
it through yeah the Arcane model
and then yeah we tested out uh just like
locking off the faces and and we talked
about this in the spider-verse video but
uh that was like baby's first step into
AI animation was like
you know just having the knowledge of
the noise patterns as you had kind of
described it to me I was like oh if we
just lock off the noise pattern on the
face
you know that'll work pretty well but
all the while in the background you were
working on like the
version of that process which yeah which
we won't go into detail on that exact
process yet yeah but we can talk about
what like the goals what we've been
trying to do and like the problems we've
been trying to solve and what you guys
will eventually see when the video comes
out
but yeah you know it's this idea of
going like hey so if you use this this
diffusion model that's effectively good
at visualizing anything
um you know so if you have this model
where you've like just vetted a lot of
images
I guess you can use that to make your
image look like anything you want to
look like you know you can everything
becomes reference you know it becomes a
blocking it's like I can just stand
there in front of a wall as an example
like hey I want a person to be in this
form but I want them to be an astronaut
you know and then it draws an astronaut
kind of in the same pose
and like the whole idea of being able to
do this at full motion so you just do
you know every frame for 24 frames per
second
it was really like really alluring but
as we saw when we tried to do it it just
every frame was interpreted interpreted
slightly differently
so that's been a big problem we've been
trying to solve in a very like hacky way
because we're just like you know just
YouTube people using open source
software to do so but like the the whole
idea behind this is that like if we can
figure this out it
it basically eliminates the need of hard
technical work to achieve a vision and
just kind of like fast forward so you're
just getting the vision that you want
like
like the a great example is what if you
wanted to shoot a movie
on your iPhone but you wanted to look
like it was shot in Alexa yeah you know
well
can we basically create the equivalent
of an Alexa filter for the iPhone what
it uses an AI to just alter the actual
deep characteristics of an image have
you tried that
[Laughter]
we should have not and it would probably
actually work pretty decent I wonder if
that would work
[Laughter]
yeah give it a crappy picture and say
like I want like the good version of
this yeah yeah I think it would work
because like honestly I I only realized
lately I was playing with mid-journey
and uh
I forgot what I saw Maybe
some concept art or something and I was
like What if I like type something I
want with concept art but then use like
Sony A7 III Lightroom presets like all
these phrases that you associate with
like a stunning image and it just worked
I was like what the heck it's all like
all these weird fantasy things I've been
trying to mess with now are just like
super real looking
um so cool because I was I was kind of
inspired by what is it like uh did you
ever see those those Keith showfield
ones uh he's been this guy a music video
guy or directing guy yeah posts on
Twitter he makes these like remakes or
like fake fake 80s movies oh I've been
seeing these all over YouTube yeah yeah
it's like a certain style
um and I think uh the free one of the
phrases he was using to like really hone
in on the vibe was DVD screen grab yeah
yeah and so I started playing with that
too and boom lo and behold if I type the
80s movie screen grab DVD specifically
DVD screen grab and then go off on a
tangent there it would make things look
like still frames from an 80s movie and
you can just start doing whatever the
heck you want after that yeah um so I
mean there are ways to do that with with
the fusion also I mean my journey is a
diffusion model so have you seen like
the dark souls or the bloodborne ones I
didn't I saw the uh bloodborne ones are
kind of like Cronenberg the Cronenberg
ones yeah
I saw a uh Halo in the style of the 1984
Dune and it was oh awesome yes I I
really like those because Keith
Schofield the one that was doing like
people would angrily reply to like the
picture you'd post yeah take that as a
subtitle and put that on like a like a a
tormented human monster hybrid like
that's what they're saying that yeah no
because you did this fake my love David
cronenberg's Galaxy of Flesh and it's
just all these scientists with like
weird flesh robots and it looks like
it's a straight up wacky it's amazing
yeah and people you know obviously been
like I can't believe you'd do this you
you were what a terrible kill yourself
treacherous person you know you're so
terrible like then some you know
obviously some BuzzFeed articles like
people are slamming this guy
come on this guy's literally effing
around with a silly AI image generator
and people are treating him like Hitler
well it turned into art once he started
taking those quotes of these tormented
angry individuals it truly did and then
showing the US the monster yeah
subtitle on there yeah of their anger
yes this is a tragedy and you should
burn all you hold dear it's like
like it's so good it's so good unlike
the other Jordan I do most of my
learning away from the computers I'm
doing producing I'm doing sword fighting
I'm doing Muay Thai so I need a wallet
that's going to keep up with my active
lifestyle so that's why I'm here to talk
to you about today's sponsor Ridge so my
favorite thing about the ridge wallet is
that it comes in over 30 colors and
styles this wallet is made with RFID
blocking technology that protects you
from digital pickpocketers also each
wallet comes with a lifetime warranty
the wallets have over 50
000 five-star reviews The Ridge team is
so confident that you'll like it that
they'll let you test drive it for 99
days you can send it back for a full
refund if you don't like it I keep our
little security card in here because I
actually just used it today to get into
the studio welcome Jordan there's room
for 12 different cards in here and plus
there's room for cash on top of the
wallet they also make a bunch of other
amazing great gifts they have this
backpack that's my personal favorite I'm
taking this to Italy they have keycases
they have watches and they have stylish
Rings If you go to ridge.com Corridor
crew you can get up to ten percent off
that's ridge.com corridorcrew for up to
ten percent off like you know like the
last podcast where we talked about
legalities of AI art you know it's I
think it's really important you know for
when that came out and all the stuff
surrounding it it was very important to
not
have like a bias you know or not
not like come to eat like a judgment on
it because of this legal aspect but you
know as I guess I don't know how you
guys feel but
really feels like people are kind of
kind of blowing this there's a big
there's a huge like h i mean it's just
the internet thing these days like
there's these huge like hate fests on
things yeah but I've seen like a lot
like a lot of really great artists that
I respect you know like on Instagram
like you know when the the no AI Banner
came out
they're all like reposting it I'm like
like I like your work but I also like
this too you know it's like yeah yeah I
mean there's always been like there's so
many misunderstandings around I mean
just look at the comments of the other
like the videos we uploaded this past
week about that lawsuit everybody's like
yeah I wonder if this program's gonna
get sued it's like the program's not
copyright infringement the actual like
the actual AI program like the diffusion
model the master structures there's zero
copyright infringement that's that's a
node like there's no legal issues
whatsoever with that like people think
that the AI program is what's like
what's getting sued and where the
copyright issues are it's like no it's
just it's just a model it's just a
single trained model
and there's already thousands of models
out there you know
um yeah
and I think it's something that's
something important to explore but just
like
you know people have characters in their
minds of what AI is and AI is a really
cool term from Hollywood that we're
using to describe it's actually just
statistics it's just equations it's just
statistics equations yeah it's not like
it's not an actual intelligence it's
just a algorithm where you can feed it a
solution that you're looking for and
it'll slowly find an optimized way to
get to that solution it's a cool
computer tool and it's very powerful but
it's that's that's all it is you know
yeah I I understand the perspective of
artists though like I feel like
I I kind of really came around to that
just
uh I feel like this year I've been
getting more of a respect for like the
Manual Arts illustration painting and
stuff and and the work that goes into
that and
I I do think there is something messed
up about having these data sets pulling
from artists without their consent
um but I think the most like the people
that we can all unite against are the
people who think they're like prompt
engineers and that makes them an artist
you know like yeah the flip side's
pretty silly too yeah
they're art I mean at the end of the day
if you spend if you spend enough time in
the world of like Fine Arts you realize
that the only thing that actually
matters is the concept yeah at the end
of the day like medium format all that
stuff is super cool but the thing that
hits you is the idea you know so
you can have a cool concept that is
delivered through your prompt and it can
be clever and it's like damn that's a
really cool idea of our prompt and it
gives you a cool image you know that's
art
but it's not like a person didn't paint
the image but like yeah it's a cool
concept but I I don't know it's like
it's it's half we we've talked about
this differently though it's like
concept versus execution I mean honestly
in the past though like we I think we've
had conversations too where it's like
concept and ideas don't matter
it's the execution that does and so now
this is it's a weird gray area where
it's like okay hold on
is making an AI image an execution of a
concept or not it can be I mean it could
be I suppose yeah so it's it's kind of
like you can't Define it you just gotta
like does it make you feel something it
doesn't feel special and yeah you know
what's AI art when you look at air it's
like wow it's air there's like something
not exciting about a lot of AI art
because it is so derivative to use the
term the other video do you have this
thing now sometimes I'll scroll down
like my Instagram or my explore page and
I'll see a cool image and I'll
instinctively like click on it and go to
the hashtags to see if it says mid
Journey or anything because I'm like
I'll do that once in a while yeah but
also I think it shows how much art is
formulaic that people make that's true
yeah you know it's like how many like
silhouetted like
cartoon character with clouds and a blue
whale in the sky can you like see before
it's like I guess human beings are just
AI you know
the astronaut in space CG render you
know it's like oh yes give me some
astronaut floating in space CGI render
yeah I mean at this point like every
Marvel character is basically just a
human being version of a diffusion model
of a superhero you know they all kind of
look the same they all kind of look
different
yeah
I don't know it's it's crazy stuff but
like
you know forgetting all that [__]
like because there's a lot of [__]
around it you're getting all that
[__] just going to a tool that can
replicate visual forms and attach them
to Words which at its core is what it is
you know so you get away from all like
the anime and Instagram posturing like
the thought was can we use this
technology
to let us make an actual anime like
full-blown hey those are anime
characters on the screen talking and
moving and like actually doing
interesting things yeah and it's not
like just a jumbled mess and skip the
drawing part and skip the drawing part
which is an important part of anime but
not necessarily always the most
important part of anime right it's an
animation thing like when when people
when Pixar became a thing there were
people like ah hand-drawn animations
better and it's like it doesn't matter
stop ranking things do you like Toy
Story it's a great it's a great movie
you know what and it doesn't make like
two-dimensional cartoons bad they're
also great but like that's kind of what
I see here is like if we can come up
with this new version of like animation
that is cool and it works like yeah
we're not trying to say it's hand-drawn
frame by frame cartoons but I can still
scratch that itch that like 3D animation
and you know hand-drawn animation all
that kind of scratches but what if you
could get to that stage of having like
an awesome animation in like
a matter of minutes as opposed to days
well I'm interested like do you guys I
think you had mentioned the same like do
you feel like this is The Logical
conclusion of these videos or like the
the highest form of these videos where
it's like before you were doing
you know making live action plates kind
of look like that anime style but now
it's like fully yeah I think it's like
one degree below like the degree above
this is uh like making things feel like
it's rendered or 3D animation like that
I think could be
I mean it's that also with the Alexa
style transfer concept they're both kind
of one of the same but uh but yeah it's
like because I think you know with you
know creating AI images it's like each
one's different yeah so going so doing
like an anime approach where okay yeah
each frame is going to be different
makes sense for where things are at
right now so as far as like peaking with
what's available this week you know it
feels like that yeah um so until yeah
because sure you can do the Arcane 3D
model Styles or some something like that
but
it won't have the motion of it like each
frame will look great but it won't have
the Motions so that's where it's like
okay something cartoony or anime-esque
functions better in this world which is
I think what we've also discovered is
that like animation is still very much
at the heart of this thing it's just
it's a much
it's a much more direct form of
Animation where it's almost like
puppetry combined with like solid basic
animation in your timeline like so
here's the thing so we we look at
Classic anime like from the 90s when you
don't have like fancy computer Graphics
like so 3D animation I mean they're 3D
animation exists but you don't really
have that in anime like you know anime
animation at the time you have a lot of
flat planes moving at different speeds
yeah and you know with that tool they've
like the artist back then did a million
different things and they're all amazing
and you watch classic cartoons like this
is really cool stuff and there's no
reason why you can't keep doing that
like yeah sure you can build a 3D model
these days and make stuff really fancy
but you can still do all the stuff that
looked really awesome that was just
basic 2D animation and the really cool
thing is right now doing that basic 2D
animation like in your editing timeline
is real time and it happens instantly
and you just do it you can watch it you
can move things around and just you know
try it again like that would be such a
dream for any animator back then to
literally at a speed as fast as they can
think they can animate you know they can
make the background move the foreground
can move it can zoom in the character
can you know slide across the screen and
it just happens instantly and like we
always talk about that being the dream
for us as like artists and filmmakers is
just being able to work at the speed of
thought so like when I step back and
look and I look at the the picture right
now what you can do it's like you can do
all the tricks from the 90s and all the
arrows before in animation like all the
layering tricks you can do that now at
the speed of thought so take that and do
that and don't don't try to do more than
that just try to execute on that as well
as you can it's like being really good
at playing a bucket right there's people
who are really good at playing drums on
a bucket
it's a basic instrument but like they
can do some really awesome stuff so it's
like start there before you go and buy a
crazy drum set
um so combining that concept within us
as characters filmed on a green screen
means now we get to control all of our
movements we could get to control all of
our poses lighting is as easy as putting
up a real light and just shining it on
us and then you take this and you turn
the the filmed and acted video of us as
if we are now puppeteering an anime
character and you turn it into an anime
character and then you do all your hand
animation which you still have to do so
like real animation comes into play here
and suddenly you start looking at a
cartoon and it starts to hit like a
cartoon and it has like the visual
metaphors and the visual energy of a
cartoon and like the style and like when
we watch the rough edits right now like
of this anime video we're making like
every time every once in a while it pops
back into regular footage because we
don't have a shot done and it just looks
really there's just two losers
[Laughter]
anime characters just screaming at each
other and it cuts to like dumpy Nico and
dorky Dean
like doing it from there but it's
working and it's really cool and like
the fact these shots are coming together
is really kind of inspires me because
I'm like I just made a cool shot and it
only took me 20 minutes and I can make
another cool shot and I can go on a
green screen I can just film a cool shot
and I literally just it all just happens
at the speed of thought it's like hey
Sam what if I do this Motion sounds like
cool I'll do this video with my dang
phone to get a cool path like through it
and then we just do it and it's done
like there's no like crazy steps you
have to take from there you don't have
to like have a crew do anything you have
to light anything you don't have to like
do any set dressing you almost don't
have to do any visual effects you know
you just you just run it through then
the pipeline to apply the look which is
not just a click of a button it's
actually rather complicated but then out
the other end comes this element that
you just do some basic animation on and
now you have a cartoon yeah man it's
it's so exciting I think I feel like
every time we take a step back and look
at it it's like
so great like I mean because no nobody's
doing anything close to this with the AI
stuff that that I've seen yeah nobody's
doing I mean there's like little tester
like us and there's not posting it yeah
yeah perhaps but I think we're kind of
ahead of the curve by quite a bit here
yeah hopefully yeah I feel like I'm
excited about at least for the future of
this specific application of it is like
when like we talk about when it will
understand temporarily how these images
are are coming together and like I mean
even little things like having
like it could do a face track before you
put it in and then turn an actor's face
into something that like only latent
space will understand and then it kicks
out something that will perfectly get
what you want and then it gives you like
vectors for things and
um I feel like all that's I mean just
with how fast this has come along I feel
like all that's coming
um like I even sent you something
yesterday like the I was looking at uh
Bruce Tim
who did Batman the Animus series he had
uh like all these drawings uh kind of
characters cool guys yeah like character
sheets for like okay if Batman's uh
looking up you don't want to you know
you only draw the the lower part of the
chin if you really have to and
like being able to give those rules
instead of to an artist who has there be
like [__] I gotta draw another picture
like the AI just learns how to do that
and then you as the
person coming up with this piece can
just be like I'm gonna set the rules and
it can do all the boring stuff and
that's I mean that's kind of what dream
Booth is in a way that's how I equate
dream Booth to be like where it's like
here's the rules of what this object is
looking like generally
yeah exactly it's just going here's
visual forms and they are tied to this
this token this word and if this token
is present
make these visual forms present in the
image that's like all there is to it you
know
yeah
it's really really crazy
because if we put this out and it works
well like I'm kind of hoping we build a
little bit of a community around it of
people who are trying to also figure it
out and make it work
because we kind of just might unlock a
way to do
cartoons any kind of cartoon really
in a matter of you know doing a couple
days of like shooting on a green screen
in a few days on a computer rather than
like weeks with a team of 40 people
doing animation by hand
yeah so
yeah it's pretty pretty crazy it also
lets you just tell stories in a really
simple way like this this story takes
place in a cathedral
you know it's really hard to shoot in a
cathedral and it involves
character is wearing very fancy costumes
which would be very complicated to get
looking good on set
yeah like I simultaneously hate green
screen filming but also like love it at
the same time yeah same because like
it's comfortable it's air conditioned
yeah but like before 20 like right
around the whole I think it was like
right when my daughter was born and it
was like that was right when the
pandemic started so I started the Unreal
Engine thing then and uh
like the like what I was seeing in that
was like okay holy [__]
we're trying to do these crazy ideas in
these crazy locations with crazy things
and it's like oh this is sweet unreal is
like okay I can use this tool to just do
that you know uh where it's like okay
you want a virtual camera thing or you
want to use volume or like just even
using mocap suits and doing it all CG
it's like okay well now I'm seeing that
tool to allow you to do that and this
whole process of like delving into a ir
and all that stuff it's like it's the
same thing it's the same feeling of like
oh cool
another tool that like just broadens The
Horizon of what you can do yeah it's
funny like unreal is almost like the
other end of the spectrum of or two
sides of the same coin where unreal is
like it gives you control over literally
everything
and then AI just does everything but you
have like zero control over it yeah but
but the benefit still of both is that
like there's this huge like speed Factor
yeah doing it I was like okay you're
doing an animation cool here's a really
fast way to do that and unreal is like
okay well let's say you want something a
little more specific and clear you know
like you can still yeah bust through
that stuff super super fast yeah I mean
what we're basically trying to do what
we're trying to develop is basically the
equivalent of a motion capture method
for AI where it's like I want to create
a character how do I motion capture so
to speak with a picture that's kind of
what we're doing it's like you film
ourselves doing a certain way and then
out from the other end comes at our
character acting a certain way and like
with Unreal Engine it's like you have to
feel you have to record yourself wearing
a special suit
yeah and then out from the other end
comes a character yeah wearing I guess
another special suit but that one's made
out of polygons but pretty soon like
with the text to 3D stuff it's gonna be
like you know prompt my character then
put on a mocap suit and then it just act
as that character in it that's going to
be the union of it all yeah yeah I think
like the big difference with this whole
video versus the like live action ones
we did though
um it's live action animes live action
anime videos yeah there's there's a ton
of similarities though like
effectively the shooting style is almost
the same like actually yeah the
cinematography itself you're right is
almost exactly the same well because
because we were filming it live action
at you know the beginning and so like
lots of similar techniques are used it's
just because it's on a green screen and
because we're like you know processing
the images so much like really the only
thing that is actually different from it
is there's just no like rotoscoping
you know yeah like that they do so much
effects work on the real footage anyways
yeah and I mean even even in the live
action green live-action anime videos
we'd always have the pop out green
screen for whenever you need like a
crazy background moment to happen or
something and it's still doing that you
know like all the same like effects and
compositing kind of still happen but
it's just this now they look like
cartoon characters there's way more
cartoony yeah it also eliminates the
need for like well I guess we never
really had motion tracking in the other
ones either the the big difference
uh between the live action and this is
that since we end up with like
two-dimensional plates and backgrounds
and stuff like that
um yeah this week as I was showing you
guys it's like I'm I'm I mean it's old
stuff it's old animation techniques but
it's the personal epiphany of having a
few 2D layers and like forcing a 3D
movement or forcing Parallax to you know
give you something that is
unachievable if you're filming it for
real well yeah we set that rule for
ourselves early on in this process which
was like I said no 3D
so anything that you want to do the look
3D has to be done by hand by eye so it's
mathematically imperfect it's wrong on
purpose yeah but it's better in a way
it's better it's more fun though yes I
don't know if you guys have had those
moments too where you visualize a shot
yeah and then you try and film it you're
like oh shoot yeah real life doesn't
work that way real life doesn't work
that way like how do you get that shot
you know like that's you can't quite fit
all that into the same frame or there's
no way to get the stuff to move like
yeah yeah it's like I have to change
focal lengths and I have to change speed
and the camera has to do this when it's
going slow motion which you can't you
know it's like yeah all these things
suddenly require yeah impossible systems
although I will say I think you can do
an animation you guys really did achieve
that with those old uh anime videos like
those those have always been my my
favorite videos that you guys did and um
I mean especially uh
what is the video called animate because
it was anime Fast and Furious at one
point right yeah for the search engine
Optimizer but anime self-driving cars I
renamed it back to just what it was
called The Working title which was just
yeah anime self-driving cars because
that's it so I watched um redline for
the first time recently was that like a
big inspiration we hadn't seen Redline
before watching that oh really no that
was just raw no it was it was just like
um
all the stuff coming out with like Tesla
and all the autonomous cars coming out
and then we were just seeing that and
going oh what if this was an initial D
race where no one touched the steering
wheel that's the best part
[Laughter]
yeah but that was the whole thing it's
just like how funny it would it be fun
yeah do a street race where the drivers
are just sitting in a box
[Laughter]
yeah but yeah there's shots in there
like um
like I was just watching it there's a
shot where like Clint is wipes the frame
and it hits like and goes to D and I
don't know I feel like you guys have
that's like
like I haven't seen other than like we
talked about like Bollywood or you know
certain other movies like you guys
really nail that style just like what is
your kind of origin story with like with
anime or like getting into that style I
mean for me it's just all about like
with with YouTube storytelling you have
to get to the point so fast that like
anime story like cinematography and
storytelling does that and like keeps it
really hyped but also
I really like having super strong visual
metaphor that matches like what's
happening in the story emotionally
and to do that with like cinematography
is really hard and expensive like think
of like a Christopher Nolan movie with
like how they have to light and dress
their sets to have him set up real nukes
yeah you know so it's like how do you
get a Vibe like a Cool vibe that
impresses people and feels fresh and
like special and it's like well you can
either go crazy with like cameras and
lighting and set decoration all that
kind of stuff it's like or you can use
Motion Graphics which is basically what
anime is you know so it's like okay
let's build Motion Graphics let's get a
character shot let's get a background
shot let's have it move a certain way
let's you know introduce visual language
and like you know we developed a lot of
that from all our action stuff and we
just dude I was watching super literal
with anime I was like working on this
dubstep guns today
and I uh I typed Sam walks down the
street like Denzel Washington and Man on
Fire and I was like wait a second
I'm just saying that reference I don't
actually have never seen that movie I
just know it's I know it's the right
reference so I started watching clips
for Man on Fire I'm like dude this is
kind of it's kind of anime
have you seen it or I've seen it yeah
that's Tony Scott right yeah like
there's this very anime there's like
weird camera moves and like exposure
shifts and like jump cuts and it's like
it's it borders on Motion Graphics it's
just it limits itself to using the film
yeah you know so so there's all sorts of
weird things that are happening there
with strange overlays that happen every
once in a while and these cuts and
exposure shifts and Camera moves and
it's it's yeah it verges on anime yeah
it's using it's it's yeah sorry just
yeah it's using the medium to tell a
more heightened story than if the camera
was just filming something yeah it's
like once you have like elements that
are now panning and scanning across the
screen even if it's like really basic
motion you're animating your shot and
like you just turn the dial up a little
little bit more and you enter the realm
of cartoons and Anime you know I guess
we keep saying anime but it's basically
like any cartoon right it doesn't just
apply to anime the specific storytelling
style of anime though is just because we
want to try to make baseball hyper
dramatic and then we just stick with the
theme because anime makes things hyper
dramatic it's just because we were all
watching Attack on Titan
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know I like that hyper
drama that like operatic storytelling
because
you know everything is just a [__]
reskin of everything else like Call of
Duty's a reskin of I guess another Call
of Duty which is a reason another Call
of Duty which is risk in a battlefield
Just reskin Call of Duty like you've
played all the games you've watched all
the movies you've read all the stories
so like any story can be dramatic right
it's how it's delivered to you it
doesn't matter so
anime storytelling you know in our
videos is all about just taking inane
things just a baseball a fidget spinner
an AI car race
uh and like taking that and being able
to tell a hyper dramatic story that's
just as gripping about fidget Spinners
and winning 100 bucks as it would be
about like saving New York City from
Aliens yeah because the function of
everything's exactly the same you can
watch a movie about New York City
exploding and not give a crap about
everybody you can watch a different
movie about New York City exploding and
it like hits you you're like oh my God
like so many people died yeah I think of
like the end did you guys see Man of
Steel yeah yeah another they exploded
New York City yeah it's like the last 30
minutes it's like everything's exploding
they're punching each other for 30
minutes and it's like it doesn't yeah it
doesn't feel as intense as a guy
freaking about to spin his finished
fidget spinner yeah yeah
or uh you know a Watchman did you
remember that scene in Watchmen the HBO
series oh wait have you seen it in the
HBO series which which scenery he's
talking about squid
oh yeah well that like that hits
different than that man you know blowing
up buildings yeah which is an
interesting I mean it's total tangent
but it's an interesting difference
between the Zack Snyder adaptation and
the book is like he set out to create
this like perfect adaptation of Watchmen
but then totally changed the meaning of
the ending
um and it wasn't that bad his Watchman
ending no I feel like it's a it's like
he made the like basic action movie
version of Watchmen
um and that that is the the
take that makes it like the take on that
ending that makes sense for that version
of it but um Zack Snyder kind of makes
anime he does yeah I mean it's it's all
about having like hyper detailed
cinematic language paired with your
storytelling and your moments in the
movie your story beats but also making
sure the story beats are good enough
that you can do cool shots yeah like
it's like what do I need to film this
shot oh a camera on a tripod I need to
rewrite the script you know it's like
change everything until every shot is
Justified being wacky and crazy it's
like okay this shot's me flying in
towards their face and this shot zooms
out from the ear and spins around their
head and flies back into like the flames
in the background this shot they're just
in this in the Galaxy because they're
talking about something else you know
it's like get crazy with it and make
sure your story can support that and
like like say I just love that the Sam
Raimi Spider-Man movies I feel like have
that as well like I always think of that
shot this was our beat for beat like
perfect yes you know yeah dude same
remix yeah those those movies are I love
those movies but there's the shot in
Spider-Man 2 where uh doc Ox like on the
rooftop or no Spider-Man swinging and it
pulls out from Doc's Ox eye and he's
like on the top of the building
um and there's shots uh like most of the
new Marvel movies kind of suck but he
did that new
um uh freaking yeah doctor strange and
there are Mo there are like Sam Raimie
moments in it and they're so good just
like weird like Kaleidoscope like fading
between things it's it's um yeah I love
his Medgar right outside a little bit
too you know egg right for sure yeah
yeah I think he's definitely in that
vein yeah let me attribute to anime but
at the end of the day it's it's
animation and it's high energy animation
and just figuring out a way to bring
that to
the filmmaking but also in a way to do
it where it's like not cost prohibitive
or time prohibitive yeah just like I
don't know it gets me really excited
yeah I mean it's really just like at the
end of the day it's like okay you're
using a you have an image it's like what
do you got to do with it now it's like
is that is it when you call cut is that
the end of
the moment or is there something else
that you're gonna be doing on top of
that
I will say that because of this new
project that we're doing
I've never seen
I've never seen an animated character
break character after a director says
cut
but now I've seen it and it's very
surreal to see a cartoon character who's
like acting and then stops acting in the
clip ends and you're like that's weird
yeah I feel like goes and eat some chips
yeah like no one would ever animate a
cartoon character from the frame after
they don't need it but like because
we're taking real clips of ourselves you
know like I'm a shot of like acting
acting and then you know we crack and we
start laughing and then like you know
you relax and like you start to walk off
screen and that's where the clip ends
and then once you process everything you
do everything you now have a cartoon
character that's acting acting acting
and then stops acting starts laughing
and like starts to walk off frame and
it's just such an odd thing to say it's
like somebody taking off their mocap
suit well after the day yeah
jpo on one of the new Star Wars movies
just like falling down to the ground is
the character getting pulled along yeah
yep
I yeah we've been very like
hush on this anime video because hey I
think it's a really good video with a
good story and I don't like spoil it
because it's only like seven minutes
long
and B because I think the visual effect
that we're going to do is really special
and people are gonna be like wowie so I
want I want that to hit
and that's why we're being really
careful about to show anything until we
get there you just want to follow
through on our promise we're here on
Mike's being like we can make a cartoon
in 20 minutes and everybody's like yeah
right it's like okay for us to be able
to say that we need to do it yes and
like there'll probably be some shots
where people will be like oh that looks
a little weird but there's already been
shots yeah you look weird
I mean of course it's good yeah yeah
it's gonna look a little weird it's
gonna look a little AI whatever okay but
that's the kind of the point it's like
this isn't an anime it's not hand-drawn
animation we're not stealing jobs it's a
new form yeah that's it that's an
interesting point with the like the AI
is gonna steal jobs because at least for
the stuff that we'd be making it's like
we wouldn't have hired animators to do
this yeah live action this video exists
because of the technology not not like
ah finally we get to stop paying this
like Korean Studio to do this dude this
video is so cool that we're hiring
someone right now to make art about the
video and yeah so that Shop's not not
getting replaced either that's actually
that's often what happens when something
comes along that that amplifies human
power it doesn't make us less productive
it makes us more productive you know
obviously like there's nuance and
everything but like
if a tool comes along that makes it
easier for somebody to make a cool film
that doesn't mean there's less cool
films coming out it means there's more
cool films coming out and more projects
being made you know yeah that's
literally all it means yeah yeah it's
like I I really like the days when
cameras weighed 100 pounds because then
you only had good movies coming out
you know think of all the people
carrying cameras that lost her
jobod the French guy who uh with the
third leg
what was his name
yeah I know he started the whole
industry that consumed him
and then GoPro comes out and threatens
his whole job yeah sorry
people people do lose their jobs to
technology technology advancing though
which is definitely sad but yeah poor
Apple farmer they stole all his boxes
I know right
sorry it's sorry it's it's I don't want
to like it's the it's the only natural
response to just seeing so much
like so many people freaking out about
it you know a lot a lot of it is just
you gotta like it's just drama it's just
also people living in the gossip land
it's not even just drama it's just like
this stupid social media thing still
vocal minority you know when are people
going to burn out on this you know this
is for another podcast but I I wonder I
feel like we're close to a burnout phase
on social media where people are like ah
screw this this sucks you know yeah I
think it's pretty close I I think what's
cool about Instagram speaking of art is
like I can fill my Instagram feed with
just like beautiful art and like every
time I get on there it's just like cool
stuff that people trying to control that
Instagram feed and Facebook just wants
to they just want my feed so bad and
like do not show me suggested posts and
like I've I purposely like don't scroll
down to like little videos they have
playing I don't want to see your random
[__] I didn't follow these people yeah
but like all the other ones I I deleted
that like years ago yep same my life is
much better for it I agree
but I was going to say about the like I
feel like that the
the opposite of this stealing jobs are
not the opposite of the stealing Jobs is
you know what if instead of your
animated series that you love coming out
every year or every few years because it
takes so long like it becomes like a
weekly series on YouTube or something
it's like now that's potential where
instead of you know
like one person getting to make their
thing and everybody else has to be like
all right I guess I'll do the in-between
drawings or something it's like each
individual artist will be able to like
just create a bunch of character sheets
and then feed that in and be like okay I
want to tell my story now and then they
can tell that too as a
an audience of maybe like 10 hundred
thousand people and make like a good
living instead of just being like I'm
gonna work on this other person's thing
and I'm gonna probably make the same
amount and not be happy at all you know
yeah no it's it's a very it's so what
happened to filmmaking with YouTube it's
like Sam and I you know everybody else
you're like we're not making giant
multi-million dollar movies you know
it's like that'd be cool but that's not
what we're doing but yet we get to make
what we love we're happy and I think the
people that watch our stuff are happy
also it's like because technology got to
the point where we could do it and we
could make stuff that people enjoyed and
people
are you able to just watch it and it's a
beautiful thing yeah and the technology
will now allow
us to make
the ideas that we think are so far off
in terms of like the execution I can't
do that because it has this crazy world
there's these crazy characters how like
I can't do that it's like oh maybe I can
now yeah and that to me is like that is
the most exciting part of it like even
if all of our jobs do get taken in five
years like if in the fourth year I can
make the thing that I've always wanted
to make yeah and then I have to go like
start a restaurant in some small town or
something just like I'll be okay with
that at the end of the day it's just it
just means more art and more artists and
you know what it might it's gonna make
the value of individual pieces of art
perhaps go down like I heard a really
good analogy like if you had a machine
that could turn rocks into gold it
wouldn't make gold worthless right it
wouldn't mean there's less gold like it
would just mean that you have a lot of
gold well you know I mean there would be
some serious inflation yeah I think
that's no my point being my point being
is that like
it's like the uses for gold still exist
and it's very useful it just becomes a
lot less hard to get it right I see like
everybody gets to have gold jewelry
everybody gets to have gold plated USB
cables like it just becomes a thing like
and yeah it's like somebody who had like
a you know a gold collection because
they were saving their money it's like
they're like no it's like yeah it sucks
but you know gold doesn't become useless
it just becomes it's really hard to get
turmeric a few hundred years ago yeah
you know yeah everybody seems to
conflate like more availability yeah oh
Art's gonna be easier to make Art's
gonna become worthless and useless it's
like no it's not gonna be useless it's
gonna be just as useful as be just as
potent and it's gonna hit your emotional
triggers just as hard you know yeah
writing
it's just gonna be a lot less I guess
anyway scarce you know there's not gonna
be well actually you know what there
probably will be cultural touchstones I
don't know like it's weird this is one
of those weird things like when you
remove all broadcast stations and movie
theaters and like you know streaming
services do human beings naturally work
towards just having shared cultural
experiences that just pop out and become
a thing I don't know I think it's that I
think a little bit that will have been a
rare factor of having a massive society
that only has like
small media like uh touchstones or like
places where you can go to consume media
because it's just I mean it's a 20 20th
century phenomenon though because think
about like I mean sure music in like the
18th century you know you can write that
down on sheet music and then give that
to someone else
um like that's the closest thing
previously you know if you painted a
picture or took a photograph like sure
you could maybe
make more photos based off of your
negatives I think but like a painting no
that's there's only one there's only one
you know so you have music that's able
you can transfer that across you know
borders uh but then in the 20th century
you know you have like radio telegram
blah blah to TV and then movies and
stuff so it's like a
still like an overall recent phenomenon
you know what so well and really like
the fir the first mediums of art that
were made for Working Class People
because like you're bringing up
paintings like oh I also forgot books
yeah books
like that's the crazy thing is like we
think of like you think of the Mona Lisa
or something like that and it's like oh
I see that everywhere but that was a
well I don't know about the Mona Lisa
but like you should only be able to see
it when you went to see the Mona Lisa
yeah in somebody's house like a rich
guy's house so people would make like
you know replicas what are a thing too
so I guess they did do that back then
they did use replicas but yeah even
still nfts so yeah
[Laughter]
yeah all right I have to go home and eat
dinner with my fam but this is this is a
good time I'm glad we can finally break
the silence on this anime video a little
bit like I still feel like we're under
selling it even though we like we did
hype it up a little bit here but I'm
gonna I'm gonna hype it up hard one more
time we're starting to speed up on it
too so I feel like it's coming we're
going to invent a new method of
Animation that enables anybody with a
computer to make cartoons
to a certain point with some weird
caveats but it'll be cool
this is gonna be sick
all right well until next time toodles
appreciate it